[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arrêtons la salle cassin à l'eau ce qui
si tard baugé c'est moi mais j'ai pas le
temps là je sur toi ça va
les attendait dominique et moi la chute
j'ai pas le temps c'est pas un gag avec
radio à appeler le 36 demain d'accord je
sais pas le temps toujours trop c'est
l'information perso c'est que les filles
équivalent des trucs comme ça le fait
réveillé ma femme tu sais pas d'où cela
n'importe quoi mais vous dites n'importe
quoi franchement c'est donc je prends
une smart électrique c'est tout j'ai
rien de fait l'extraordinaire 3 jamais
justifié la expliquez moi juste pourquoi
je suis si fier parce que j'ai pas
toujours en battant sedan bat santiago
végétons patron mais non julien est
d'abord ils étaient capturés mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bbc lui bernard bernard merci d'avoir
été là avant bernard mais tu as tu
savais que les stagiaires s'amuser à
cracher dans ton chasse et à la radio
dans ce jeu suit oui quoi c'est dans
celui de julien oui
à céret
en fait il faut que les basques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais avoue trouver des infos sur lui
lorsque après midi j'avais autre chose à
faire
[Rires]